esta carretera conduce mykolaiv al
puerto de gerzón a 68 kilómetros al sur
que está en control de las fuerzas rusas
desde marzo y está en la entrada de
postas procaps que también alcanzó a
estar en manos enemigas
actualmente está bajo el control de los
ucranianos que los hicieron retroceder
son pocas las casas que han quedado
inmunes a los bombardeos
solo será cuestión de tiempo cuando
logremos hacerlos retroceder aún más y
logremos liberar gerson
esto es el frente
los rusos están a sólo 2 km y su
presencia se siente permanentemente
el colegio está en ruinas el ataque a la
edificación fue hace varias semanas pero
los bombardeos no cesan y la destrucción
aumenta con los días
[Aplausos]
la soledad de las calles contrasta con
el la dra de los perros que han sido
dejados atrás por sus dueños
los hombres responsables de detener a
los rusos pertenecen a la brigada
mecanizada 28 del ejército ucraniano
el color negruzco en su comandante
adjunto
en el momento la situación está estable
el enemigo está tratando de atacar a
nuestras fuerzas pero gracias a nuestros
hombres los hicimos retroceder puesto en
un vicio antes de seguir su camino el
coronel hace un recuento del armamento
del enemigo
ven y tienen todo bmp tanques cohetes
antitanques muchas muchas armas
many many web es el comando central
ucraniano ha dicho que las fuerzas rusas
que están en gestión están tratando de
buscar las debilidades de las fuerzas
ucranianas y tomarse todo este sector
del país
vital es uno de los hombres responsables
de que el ejército ruso no avanza en
este frente lleva peleando contra ellos
desde hace ocho años en el donbass
entonces tenía 19 muchos de sus
compañeros han muerto
la pelea no fue tan dura para nosotros
ellos eran quienes atacaban pero
salieron corriendo fue una batalla a
nuestro favor nosotros
[Música]
saben que la defensa de este lugar es
estratégica y de ellos depende que ni
mykolaiv ni odesa caigan en manos
enemigas